j'ouvre notre second thème qui va nous
faire voyager très loin jusqu'à la lune
pourquoi pas vers la planète Mars dans
trois jours ce 11 décembre le vaisseau
Orion retrouvera la terre après un
périple de plus de 2 millions de
kilomètres autour de notre satellite
pourquoi renvoyer des humains sur la
lune quels sont les enjeux économiques
et géopolitiques de la conquête spatiale
avant d'en débattre on décolle à bord de
cette fusée la fusée SLS pilotée par
Flora sauvage Objectif Lune avant
d'explorer mars la conquête spatiale
redécole 50 ans après la mission Apollo
le 21 juillet 1969 ni l’amstrong était
le premier homme à marcher sur la lune
un demi-siècle plus tard les Américains
ont lancé une méga fusée la plus
puissante du monde pour la première
mission non habité du nouveau programme
phare de la NASA Artemis sans astronaute
à bord se voltest doit faire le tour de
la Lune sans y atterrir pour permettre
de confirmer que le vol est sûr pour un
futur vol habité il a fallu du temps
pour en arriver là
la dernière fois que nous étions sur la
lune s'est fait Apollo 17 donc nous
avons encore du chemin à parcourir ce
n'est qu'un vol d'essai
la NASA vise 2025 pour retourner sur la
surface de la Lune soit 3 ans avant la
programmation initiale un coup
d'accélérateur rendu possible par
l'arrivée des sociétés privées telles
que spaces d'Elon musk qui ont réduit
les coûts si la Russie est en retard la
Chine multiplie l'émission réussie sur
la lune et tente de s'imposer comme la
deuxième puissance dans la conquête de
l'espace quant à l'Agence spatiale
européenne son budget est en net hausse
et chacun sait que l'argent est le nerf
de la guerre et le nerf de la guerre
spatiale notamment et bien aujourd'hui
c'est 17 milliards d'euros ou presque
qui vont être consacrés à l'Agence
spatiale européenne si la lune intéresse
autant les États-Unis la Chine et
l'Europe c'est pour son accès à l'eau
une ressource qui pourrait permettre aux
grandes puissances de la conquête
spatiale de produire du carburant afin
d'aller ensuite explorer la planète Mars
la course contre la montre est bel et
bien relancée on est parti pour notre
second débat avec Pascal
ultreguerard bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
directrice adjointe des programmes au
Centre national d'études spatiale CNES
François Forget bonsoir bonsoir
bienvenue à vous aussi vous êtes
directeur de recherche au CNRS
spécialiste de l'exploration du système
solaire et membre de l'Académie des
Sciences Philippe et Marie-José bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes rédacteur en chef du
magazine Ciel et Espace et auteur de ce
livre ils ont marché sur la Lune aux
éditions
Belin question toute simple pour
commencer Pascal ultra Guerra pourquoi
retourner sur la Lune à quoi ça sert
sinon c'est déjà bien à nous faire rêver
oui alors en fait on souhaite retourner
sur la Lune cette fois-ci pour y rester
davantage et en particulier pour
préparer éventuellement des missions
plus lointaines évidemment on pense tous
à la planète Mars qui fait peut-être
encore plus rêver que que la Lune et
donc voilà c'est à l'objectif c'est
vraiment de préparer toute une
logistique pour permettre d'établir une
présence plus durable de l'homme ou de
la femme et de la femme et de la femme
et ça c'est très bien on va on va
pouvoir en parler François Forget cette
mission Artémis donc retour des humains
sur la lune c'est quand même ça le
projet si tout va bien juste avant la
fin de la décennie ça fera plus de 55
ans que ce n'est pas arrivé pourquoi la
NASA mais aussi les Soviétiques ou alors
le l'Europe l'Agence spatiale européenne
pourquoi c'était plus un objectif de
poser le pied sur la lune alors on l'a
pas souligné mais c'est ça coûte
extrêmement cher de faire un tel
programme donc dans les années 60 on a
connu une période tout à fait unique où
il y avait la guerre froide bien sûr et
les Soviétiques avaient commencé à
démontrer qu'ils étaient d'excellents
ingénieurs d'excellents chercheurs et
tout d'un coup les États-Unis n'avaient
d'autres choix si on voulait pas que le
reste du monde se dise c'est juste des
cowboys il fallait qu'il monte qui
savent le qui savent le faire donc le à
l'époque le budget de la Nasa a explosé
bien plus important
personnellement qu'aujourd'hui et puis
depuis vous le savez tous ça fait
littéralement 50 ans qu'on a une espèce
de ronronnement en orbite basse Soyouz
la navette spatiale la Station spatiale
internationale ça a coûté beaucoup
d'argent et il y avait plus de
ressources pour faire autre chose et
puis il y a quelques années les choses
ont changé quand même d'abord le budget
de la Nasa augmente doucement mais
sûrement il est assez important et l'un
dans l'autre grâce à l'amélioration et
technologique
on se rend compte qu'on est capable de
retourner sur la Lune et puis même
d'envisager de d'envoyer des hommes sur
Mars finalement à budget constant sans
qui a besoin d'un jeune Fitzgerald
Kennedy qui dit on va mettre tout
l'argent on va montrer au monde qu'on
sait le faire donc ça c'est un vrai
changement mais quand même Philippe
henaregeos il y a ce programme Artémis
on le doit à quelqu'un qui s'appelle
Donald Trump c'est c'est pas seulement
mais il a joué un rôle quoi c'est lui
qui a nommé le programme enfin lui son
administration qui a qui a nommé le
programme Artémis jusque-là il n'y avait
pas de programme lunaire c'est-à-dire
que il y a eu un programme lunaire sous
George Bush qui a été annulé par Obama
mais bon à mala tout ce qui avait été
commencé pour ce programme lunaire de
bouche avec continué en sourdine il y
avait par exemple la capsule Orion le
vaisseau qui était fabriqué par l'eau
qui de Martine qui avait fait un vol
d'essai en 2014 à bord d'une fusée plus
petite que la que l'actuelle que la SLS
donc c'était bien avancé et puis il y
avait tous les industriels qui voulaient
produire la fusée space land System qui
avait pas de nom d'ailleurs à l'époque
en fait qu'on appelait le sénatologie
par le Sénat américain mais elle n'avait
pas de but il y avait pas de programme
et donc ça a continué comme ça sur l'île
à être financé et qu'en Trump est arrivé
finalement le travail a été fait et lui
a dit ben on va l'appeler Artemis on va
retourner sur la Lune pour 2024 alors
2024 quand il l'a annoncé c'était la fin
de son deuxième mandat supposés donc on
voit bien que que la conquête spatiale
et la politique c'est évidemment
ça traduit pas le fait ça donne le
sentiment que finalement en 50 ans on
n'a pas tellement progressé ce qu'on va
retourner sur la Lune ce qu'ils ont fait
il y a plus de 50 ans alors peut-être
que c'est pas le sentiment
on va refaire ce qui a été fait il y a
50 ans alors c'est à la fois vrai faux
là où c'est vrai c'est que les
technologies par exemple des moteurs
fusées c'est vraiment assez similaire on
n'a pas trouvé de en 60 ans je dirais de
un nouveau quelque chose de plus
astucieux que des moteurs fusées avec un
carburant un comburant et sont pas
beaucoup plus efficaces que il y a que
dans les années 60 littéralement donc il
y a beaucoup de points communs avec ça
il faut pareil un bouclier les masses
sont les mêmes ce qui est vraiment
nouveau évidemment c'est tout ce qui est
les matériaux l'informatique c'est quand
même beaucoup plus amélioré on peut
faire plus de choses à nouveau la
différence c'est le
si vous voulez je suis retraduire ce que
je dis tout à l'heure dans les années 60
il fallait tout inventer ça a coûté
jusqu'à 4% du budget fédéral c'est une
somme énorme vraiment et aujourd'hui on
peut faire la quelque chose avec un
petit un budget la NASA c'est 20-25
milliards de dollars par an à comparer
avec l'armée américaine c'est 600 800
milliards de dollars par an et puis
parce qu'elle Trega il y a vous l'avez
dit il y a mars c'est à dire que on
retourne sur la lune pour un objectif
pour aller pour aller vers Mars mais
alors ça il faut expliquer comment on va
faire parce que ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire qu'on va on va produire du
carburant sur la lune on va on va on va
assembler des des éléments de fusée sur
la lune comment comment ça va
fonctionner l'idée c'est effectivement
de autant que possible utiliser les
matériaux sur place et d'avoir le plus
d'autonomie possible pour montrer
qu'après on peut aller vers des
destinations encore plus lointaines
puisque je rappelle que pour aller sur
Mars il faut six mois actuellement c'est
ce qui sait ce qu'il faut pour aller
là-bas donc effectivement il vaut mieux
être capable d'avoir une autonomie de
longue durée sur ce type de mission mais
la technologie pour faire ça ce que vous
décrivez c'est à dire construire sur
place j'imagine à base à base de
rigolites à la poussière de lune
du contenu dans le regolit d'accord bon
on a trouvé quoi de l'eau sous forme de
glace aux deux pôles de la lune donc il
y a on sait grosso modo qui a de quoi
faire c'est ça technologiquement
apporter un certain nombre de de
substances pour vivre de la nourriture
alors bien sûr voilà il y a un certain
nombre de choses il y a beaucoup
d'images de l'oublions jamais hein c'est
pas fait pour nous normalement
à l'époque Apollo c'est c'est aussi le
le modèle économique a changé la NASA
maintenant fait moins de choses en
interne et achètent des services faire
des industriels c'est du public privé
quoi il y a vraiment cette notion il y a
aussi tout un certain nombre de start-up
qui sont impliqués qui font les choses
de manière assez différente moins cher
et donc effectivement l'écosystème a
beaucoup évolué beaucoup plus ouvert en
fait et le lanceur enfin la fusée
qu'est-ce qui le produit déjà là c'est
du du holspace on va dire donc c'est la
NASA non non c'est la NASA est en
quelque sorte maître d'oeuvre et a
demandé à des industriels qui sont
Boeing Grumman pour les principaux et
Aero jet pour les pour les moteurs donc
son des partenaires plutôt historiques
qui agissent un peu comme des
sous-traitants et en fait on a quand
même pris sur l'étagère des choses
puisque cette fusée SpaceBall system
elle reprend beaucoup de choses de la
navette spatiale d'ailleurs
au sens propre du terme puisque les
moteurs c'était les moteurs d'occasion
qui avaient volé sur plusieurs navettes
spatiales les boosters à poudre qui sont
sur le côté plusieurs segments de ces
moteurs ont été récupérés comme on va
aller chercher à la casse sur des
boosters de navette qui avait volé
non surtout qu'on va remettre des
humains à l'intérieur le l'étage central
c'est ni plus ni moins qu'un
réservoir de navette spatial qui a été
allongé donc voilà on avait des choses
qui étaient déjà existantes on a oublié
de dire une chose mais pourquoi c'est
important de redécoller de la lune parce
qu'il y a moins de gravité c'est ça donc
il y a moins de carburant nécessaire
pour pouvoir partir vers Mars
l'idée c'est pas de faire une base
spatiale sur la lune pour aller vers
Mars le grand objectif de d'aller sur la
lune c'est avant tout pour s'entraîner
pour préparer
à vivre à vivre longtemps
d'apprendre à faire des habitats en
utilisant le sable local des choses
comme ça mais bien sûr on va pas faire
une basse spatiale sur la lune pour
aller vers Mars c'est que ce serait très
compliqué en fait d'accord même c'est
parce que je regarde une série qui est
magnifique qui s'appelle for all man
kind et qui alors c'est une chronique
sur la la bagarre spatiale entre les
États-Unis et l'URSS à l'époque
soviétique et donc ça se passe comme ça
un moment donc voilà c'est pour ça que
je suis beaucoup trop optimiste alors on
va revenir sur notre bonne vieille Terre
et sur l'action de l'Europe et sur les
moyens déployés l'Europe qui passe en
reste 17 milliards d'euros pour les
trois prochaines années voilà le le
budget qui a été adopté par l'Agence
spatiale européenne ça représente plus
17% ce qui permettra notamment d'envoyer
des astronautes autour de la Lune en
tout cas c'est le projet explication de
David Parker qui est directeur de
l'exploration humaine et robotique à
l'Agence spatiale européenne et il nous
présente son équipe de cet astronaute
dont Thomas Pesquet
au cours de cette décennie trois
astronautes de l'Agence spatiale
européenne s'envoleront vers le Lunar
Gateway notre station permanente que
nous construisons autour de la Lune
notre avant-poste pour préparer
l'exploration à long terme et si tout se
passe bien à la fin de cette décennie je
pense que nous serons prêts à envoyer le
premier astronaute européen sur la Lune
parce qu'elle utriguerra la contribution
européenne à ce programme spatial
c'est quoi c'est il y a notamment une
station qui va être
assemblée on va dire autour de la Lune
c'est ça c'est ça alors en fait l'Europe
contribue à travers deux modules de
modules un module qu'on appelle le
module esprit qui est un module un petit
peu j'irai de de logistique qui apporte
l'énergie
et pour permettre à cette station de de
d'être en autonomie et puis également un
module d'habitation qu'on appellerabe
voilà et la France est très
particulièrement impliquée dans le
module esprit qui qui est très
importante pour pour assurer cette
mission et effectivement le la façon de
travailler avec avec les États-Unis
c'est on apporte on apporte des éléments
en nature et en échange on a des vols
d'astronautes oui c'est ça c'est-à-dire
que c'est du donnant-donnant on
participe au budget et donc si Thomas
Pesquet met un jour le pied sur la Lune
c'est parce que on aura on aura fourni
module au programme américain allez-y on
peut même compléter pour l'implication
de preuve Artemis le fait que en fait
c'est l'Europe qui fournit ce qu'on
appelle le module de service de la
capsule Orion vous avez la capsule dans
lequel les astronautes sont et en
dessous vous avez tout un cylindre plein
de système pour la puissance électrique
la puissance moteur la respiration l'eau
etc et ça c'est fourni par l'Europe
c'est fait en Allemagne par la jupe
qui est actuellement c'est prévu pour
les et puis on peut compléter cela à
terme un des atouts qu'on essaie de
mettre pour espérer avoir quand même des
astronautes non seulement autour de la
Lune dans la station mais à la surface
l'Europe développe aussi un espèce de
petit cargo robotique qu'on appelle el-3
maintenant on l'appelle argonaute et qui
a un gros truc quand même un espèce
d'atterrisseur sur la lune qui amènera
du matériel donc ça fait partie des dons
entre la station spatiale en orbite
autour de la Lune et le 3 qui viendra
directement de la terre celui-là alors
je je voudrais bien comprendre pourquoi
je sais pas qui veut répondre mais
pourquoi cette option peut-être
là-dessus pourquoi est-ce qu'on
construit une station
spatiale autour de la nuit alors que
effectivement dans les années fin des
années 60 début des années 70 on allait
directement alors l'architecture choisie
pour le programme Artemis effectivement
est un peu plus complexe que celle
d'Apollo ou n'importe où on tournait
autour de la Lune on se posait là en
fait la fusée SLS telle qu'elle est
conçue avec le vaisseau Orion et non pas
assez de puissance pour faire les
manœuvres que faisait à l'époque Apollo
surtout si on veut apporter beaucoup de
choses à la surface donc il a fallu
imaginer une une station relais sur une
orbite un peu bizarre d'ailleurs qui est
une orbite très elliptique qui passe
très près de la lune et qui s'en éloigne
beaucoup jusqu'à 64000 km c'est ça passe
à 100 km et ça va jusqu'à 60 alors qu'à
l'époque d'Apollo on était à 100 km on
est resté et on avait un moteur du
module de service qui était beaucoup
plus puissant à l'époque l'objectif
était pas le même donc il manquait un
peu de de puissance dans architecture
Artemis donc à la NASA on a réfléchi
tiens on va faire une station qui
servira de relais ou on aura un module
lunaire qui arrivera par ailleurs qui ne
sera pas emporté par la fusée qui
importera les astronautes et on
s'assemblera là on fera une station une
station-service comme au bord de
l'autoroute en fin de compte et on
rentrera dans le dans le module lunaire
qui lui n'aura que fonctionne dans les
deux l'orbite jusqu'à la surface et de
remonteront pas a priori sur la surface
de la Lune il remonteront à chaque fois
alors
dans un premier temps
les Américains vont remarcher sur la
lune et ça va être courte durée comme à
l'époque d'Apollo
ça
on en est sûr
nous a dit récemment non non mais avant
qu'il y a un Européen qui marche sur la
lune il y aura d'abord des Américains et
une Américaine on va on va y venir le
prochain américain sera une américaine a
priori donc et ensuite il y a quand même
l'ambition de se poser à une dans une
zone de la lune qui est le pôle sud et
il y a très peu finalement deux zones
faciles pour se poser parce qu'il faut
que ce soit éclairé et que ce soit
éclairé en permanence le reste c'est
dans l'ombre parce qu'il y a des reliefs
et donc là à terme il va y avoir sans
doute ce qui va ressembler une base pour
des séjours plus longs cette fois mais
il y aura des astronautes qui seront un
support avec des missions de 1 à 3 mois
3 mois c'est peut-être beaucoup même
autour de la Lune dans la station
orbitale autour de la Lune la Gateway ce
fameux relais station-service qui sera
là donc on voit qu'on est dans une dans
un état d'esprit où un s'implante et où
on va rester allez voilà pour l'eau les
plus longs c'était trois jours à la
surface de la Lune pour une durée totale
de vol de presque 15 jours ça c'était
les plus les plus longs là ce sera un à
trois mois et d'ailleurs je crois
qu'avec ce cet orbite la particulière le
fait d'aller aussi loin 74000 km jamais
un humain ne aura été aussi loin de la
Terre c'est ça si je si j'ai bien lu des
en parler en fait du prochain vol oui
c'est ça quand le vol sera habité le
prochain vol ce sera juste la capsule
avec quatre astronautes qui je crois oui
dont un Canadien qui iront effectivement
plus loin que là où était jamais Apollo
et ensuite la la qualité oui donc cette
petite station elle sera dans une orbite
différente
pour le premier c'est que une des
motivations de la Gateway c'est
d'apprendre à vivre dans un espace très
lointain non protégé par le champ
magnétique de la Terre c'est un peu
technique mais ça on a besoin de le
savoir pour aller plus sur Mars plus
tard l'autre point c'est comme évoquer
le fait que le fameux atterrisseur qui
va permettre de descendre sur la Lune
on a tous en tête peut-être le module
lunaire d'Apollon et bien cette fois-ci
la NASA a sélectionné de manière un peu
ambitieuse à une fourniture de la
société SpaceX qui est une énorme fusée
qu'avec un changement de paradigme qu'on
aura un engin qui ressemble plus à
Tintin sur la lune qui va descendre
comme ça qui s'appelle le yumag dans le
dragon NASA human a une système HLS il
est pas près du tout pour être honnête
il a besoin de plein de lancement c'est
un truc très compliqué je veux juste
souligner le fait que quand ça arrivera
ça ressemblera plus à tatin sur la lune
un énorme engin on se rend pas le sud
immense des très grandes ondes comme ça
le soleil rasant ça va être assez
spectaculaire Serge le visionnaire et le
plus incroyable c'est que la NASA
officiellement annonçant en 2025
évidemment sera pas en numéro j'avance
parce qu'il y a encore plein de de de
thèmes on parlait de d'une femme enfin
une femme sur sur la lune puisque la
conquête spatiale c'est aussi une
conquête féminine je vais d'abord par
commencer en donnant la parole à
Soufiano qui est donc cette française
qui est dans la nouvelle promotion de
l'agence spatiale europ européenne elle
nous raconte c'est un rêve de petite
fille j'ai toujours rêvé en fait du
spatial depuis très longtemps ma sœur me
dit souvent en plaisantant et me dit
mais quand tu étais petite la seule le
seul poster qui avait dans ta chambre
c'était un poster d'une fusée donc oui
j'ai pensé depuis un petit bout de temps
je pense que j'ai grandi avec l'âme
d'une exploratrice toujours essayer
d'aller chercher un petit peu plus loin
ce qui se passe et puis revenir auprès
de ses paires avec un oeil nouveau il a
fallu un peu d'audace il a failli fallu
beaucoup de travail et puis surtout le
soutien de beaucoup de personnes voilà
donc la curiosité l'audace d'aller dans
l'espace oui ça me fait rêver parce que
le trigger on l'a dit tout à l'heure le
retour des humains sur la Lune il y a
aussi ce sera aussi une première ce sera
la première fois qu'une femme posera le
pied enfin les pieds sur la lune on est
d'accord on est d'accord
c'est pas seulement un symbole quoi
c'est à dire que dans est-ce que dans le
dans le dans le choix politique
finalement de la NASA derrière ce retour
ce programme lunaire il y a aussi ça
d'après vous ou est-ce que c'est pas le
premier moteur
malheureusement c'est très attendu donc
il ne pouvait pas rater ce cette attente
dans les années 70 l'opinion était pas
mûr pour ça c'est ça et leur poser la
question je ne sais pas il y a eu
combien au total qui ont posé le pied
dans les différentes missions Apollo sur
la lune 12
c'est l'un des thèmes de cette série
forum mancinne alors voilà il faut
vraiment que vous la regardez vous la
connaissez
une femme je suis sûr suffisamment
qualifié pour y aller moi je tiens à
dire une chose c'est que depuis quelques
années et en Europe on n'a pas été les
plus brillants depuis quelques années la
NASA fait vraiment un effort de
recrutement quasiment à parité au niveau
astronaute femme et la précédente
c'était Claudie ignoré dans les années
Christophe jusqu'à présent jusqu'à cette
sélection ci vous aviez que deux
astronautes femmes en Europe donc les
Américains ont fait bien mieux il y a
souvent souvent des astronautes femmes
aux États-Unis alors ici on se soigne il
y a évidemment beaucoup d'enjeux
politiques géopolitiques autour de la
conquête spatiale
Guillaume Daret c'est aussi ce que vous
avez ressenti en accompagnant Emmanuel
Macron aux États-Unis il y a quelques
jours absolument la semaine dernière on
a vu que c'était pas du tout qu'un sujet
technologique scientifique mais que ça
avait vraiment un poids politique parce
que déjà ça occupé toute une matinée de
la visite d'État d'Emmanuel Macron à
Washington il est allé au siège de la
NASA à Washington il a été reçu par le
patron c'était Kamala à risque qui était
là parce que je parle souvent de
contrôle je crois que c'est elle qui a
la responsabilité de la politique
spatiale aux États-Unis et donc a été
question de coopération il y avait
sofiano il y avait Thomas Pesquet ça
montre effectivement me disait Thomas
Pesquet alors peut-être un petit peu
franchouillard là dessus me disait qu'on
peut quasiment regarder les Américains
les yeux dans les yeux sur cette
question il me dit c'est vrai qu'il y a
des choses qu'on disait tout à l'heure
qu'ils ne savent pas faire qu'on sait
faire donc il y a des compétitions sur
le plan industriel mais c'est aussi un
sujet de collaboration il me disait de
collaboration évidemment face à la Chine
qui est très conquérante sur cette
politique spatiale le spatial on voit
que c'est quelque chose qui apparaît
comme stratégique dans la politique d'un
état presque au même titre que le
nucléaire dont on évidemment il y a
quelques instants et il me disait aussi
Thomas Pesquet que de parler et
d'intégrer cela dans une visite d'État
c'est important parce que ça permet
évidemment de faire avancer certains
dossiers beaucoup plus rapidement que si
ça se passait seulement au niveau
ministériel ou au niveau des
administrations et puis tout simplement
être dans le programme spatial on
parlait des femmes à l'instant c'est
pareil sur le plan des nationalités ce
que me disait Sophie adonos ce que nous
disait Thomas Pesquet c'est que ça donne
aussi un poids diplomatique à la France
sur la scène internationale et c'est
pour ça que Thomas Pesquet qui compte
bien être dans une dans un des
programmes Artémis il a trouvé le
meilleur agent qui soit comment dira en
football et cet âge-là il s'appelle
Emmanuel Macron je vous propose de
l'écouter c'était la semaine dernière au
siège de la NASA
vous mentionnez le programme Artemis 1 2
et 3 et nous sommes très enthousiastes à
l'idée d'y participer
[Musique]
nous avons ici l'équipe française et
Thomas est très enthousiaste et très
excité d'en faire partie il est très
très important pour nous que vous
puissiez proposer aux dirigeants
français de voler vers la Lune
nous en sommes très heureux cela nous
convient tout à fait vous voyez je pense
que si les Américains n'avaient pas
compris le message est passé la semaine
s'adresse
le patron de la NASA aussi kamalaris qui
était là donc le message est passé puis
aussi parce que les gens qui étaient là
autour de lui ou même le ministre de
l'Économie tous les ministres qui
étaient là me disaient on voit qu'au de
la même du poids politique c'est
qu'ensuite c'est quelque chose on l'a vu
avec Apollo qui essaime dans la société
c'est à dire que il y a le projet de
technologie il y a le projet
scientifique il y a le poids politique
il y a tout ce que vous allez pouvoir
décliner ensuite par exemple j'allais
dire dans l'éducation nationale si
Thomas Pesquet intègre Artemis on l'a vu
lors de son vol dans la station spatiale
internationale il y a des dizaines et
des dizaines de classes d'élèves qui ont
travaillé sur cette question là et c'est
cela aussi que ça peut permettre d'avoir
un Français dans Artemis et
effectivement Pascal
ultra est-ce qu'on regarde effectivement
le les Américains dans les yeux quoi la
France est-elle encore une puissance
spatiale ou une grande puissance
spatiale on peut dire que oui alors il
faut pas oublier aussi qu'on s'inscrit
dans une coopération européenne fait pas
les choses seules on voit il y a eu le
conseil au niveau des ministres de
l'Agence spatiale européenne il y a 15
jours les fameux 17 milliards dont on
parlait c'est du budget européen donc il
va pas uniquement servir à faire de
l'exploration mais en partie et donc et
d'ailleurs il faut rappeler aussi que
Thomas Pesquet et Sophie adonos sont des
astronautes européens avec un passeport
français et donc oui je pense que on
s'inscrit complètement dans les grandes
puissances on a vraiment pas à rougir de
de notre ambition spatiale on nous
sommes des acteurs qui comptent et on a
effectivement une bonne complémentarité
avec ce que font les États-Unis et je
pense que c'est c'est vraiment on
parlait de troc tout à l'heure voilà on
sait c'est vraiment une coopération
gagnante gagnante
sofiano elle a été choisie quand même
parmi 225 candidate et candidat Philippe
et najo c'est quoi les qualités qui sont
demandées à un astronaute aujourd'hui
d'abord un scientifique c'est il fallait
un bagage scientifique cette fois
on le voit avec la sélection finale le
bagage de pilotes voir de pilotes
d'essai n'était pas n'était pas superflu
les deux Français il y a un deuxième
français qui est dans un réserviste
elles sont tous les deux pilotes d'essai
et pilote d'hélicoptère
et pilotes décès l'hélicoptère
et puis il y a des capacités qui sont
nouvelles par rapport à l'époque qu'on
appelait celle de l'étoffe des héros
c'est plus tout à fait comme ça donc les
capacités capacités scientifiques mais
celles aussi de de suivre des missions
longues avec des coéquipiers c'est ce
qui est mise à l'oeuvre dans la station
spatiale internationale
tous les jours de 3 à 6 mois donc il y a
une dimension psychologique
un petit plus aujourd'hui qui est la
capacité à communiquer aussi parce que
on parlait des douze hommes qui ont
marché sur la Lune ils étaient
absolument capable de communiquer moins
bon communicant qui parlait pas beaucoup
avaient le sens de la formule et c'est
un peu exprimé mais il a très bien fait
les autres c'était difficile et je peux
vous dire pour pour les avoir en avoir
côtoyé quelques-uns essayer d'avoir tiré
un peu oui pour le livre dont on parlait
tout à l'heure c'est difficile même
encore aujourd'hui c'est difficile
c'était militaire ils étaient là pour
battre les Russes oui l'état d'esprit
était pas le même là on va avoir des
gens qui ont cette fonction de renvoyer
vers le public ce qu'ils font de
raconter à nous tous finalement on va
aller dans l'espace par procuration
grâce à eux il y a un peu cette
dimension là aussi alors un peu comme la
coupe du monde de foot constitué un
groupe prenez pas les meilleurs mais
prenez ceux qui s'entendent le mieux
c'est trop longtemps quand il y a vous
avez raison c'est vrai bah quand on va
en cohabite pendant alors là c'est un
peu moins longtemps c'est mais pendant
trois mois en plus dans l'espace voilà
il y a pas on peut pas ouvrir la porte
pour aller prendre l'air bref on
comprend que l'aspect psychologique soit
très important sur ces enjeux politiques
géopolitiques économiques je vous
propose tout de suite d'accueillir
mathiasarayez
[Musique]
alors c'est une surprise qu'on a fait
parce que j'avais dit je pourrais
rentrer sur la musique de Star Wars on
lui dit bah non on va pas faire ça alors
là c'est notre cadeau du jour vous êtes
le merci le padawan de la rédaction je
ne me prends pas pour Obi-Wan Kenobi
mais bon alors Mathias on va parler du
droit parce que ça c'est une dimension
importante quel droit quel législation
s'applique dans l'espace et bien écoutez
le plus vieux traité international
régissant les extérieurs
régissant les activités en matière
d'exploration remonte à 1967 une époque
où les États-Unis et feu l'URSS
faisaient la course à la Lune le traité
prévoyait alors la non militarisation de
la lune justement et des corps célestes
leur non-appropriation également ainsi
que l'interdiction de mise en orbite
d'armes nucléaires aujourd'hui en
réalité il n'y a qu'une seule loi en
dehors de la couche d'ozone elle est
française et elle régit les opérations
spatiales cette loi elle est entrée en
vigueur en 2010 mais elle n'est
applicable qu'au niveau européen alors à
qui bénéficie ce flou juridique et bien
c'est un flux juridique dans lequel ce
sont évidemment engouffrer les
Américains en 2015 les États-Unis
adoptent le Space Act qui dans les
grandes lignes autorisent les
entreprises américaines à s'emparer des
ressources extraites dans l'espace comme
le nickel des astéroïdes ou encore l'eau
sous forme de glace vous y faisait
référence présente sur la lune résultat
à l'année suivante et bien le secteur
privé américain se lance dans l'aventure
1,8 milliards de dollars investis deux
fois plus que la totalité des sommes
investis depuis l'an 2000 aujourd'hui
SpaceX l'entreprise Elon Musk tout le
monde la connaît détient 45% des
satellites en orbite basse à terme le
propriétaire de Tesla espère voir une
constellation de 2000 satellites tourner
autour de la Terre et il n'est pas le
seul à révé des toiles puisque les
milliardaires Richard Branson de Virgin
galactique et le propriétaire d'Amazon
Jeff Bezos se verrait bien mener la
guerre des étoiles une guerre qui est en
réalité bien terre à terre à qui
remportera le monopole en matière de
satellite et donc de télécommunications
est-ce qu'on peut parler Mathias de zone
de non-droit alors je n'irai pas jusqu'à
prononcer le mot Far West pour continuer
la blague mais l'espace est
effectivement par sa dimension un
terrain de jeu difficile à réglementer
l'un des exemples parlant c'est la
question des débris spatiaux et la
pollution et la pollution pardon que
cela engendre selon l'Agence spatiale
européenne environ 131 millions de
déchets gravitent autour de la Terre
posant dans certains cas de véritables
questions de sécurité concernant les
lanceurs de satellites le Centre
national des études spatiales et je
parle sous votre contrôle estime que
seulement 20% des opérateurs respectent
la réglementation un gros travail donc
doit être et les lois internationales
n'existant pas il faudra que chaque pays
transpose d'éventuelles futures règles
dans son droit national merci Mathias je
sais pas si on va vous faire ressortir
avec la musique de Star Wars ou pas
merci d'être venu nous donner tous ces
informations elles sont elles sont pas
neutres et évidemment Pascal
ultra Guerra cette question du droit et
notamment alors on va pas parler parce
que quand on parle d'espace on se rend
pas forcément compte mais évidemment les
satellites enfin notre vie quotidienne
dépend en majeure partie de
d'informations et des satellites bref je
voudrais laisser ça de côté mais la
question de l'exploitation du sol
lunaire ou alors si on va encore plus
loin du sol martien c'est totalement de
la science-fiction je veux dire c'est à
dire que le le ce que ça pourrait
rapporter une entreprise par rapport à
ce que ça lui coûterait d'aller extraire
de la matière sur la Lune par exemple
c'est c'est ça a pas de sens quoi tout
dépend ce qu'on appelle exploitation si
par exploitation on a on rêve de d'aller
chercher des ressources sur la Lune et
de les ramener sur terre il faut quand
même effectivement en raison garder
puisque ces missions on l'a vu coûte
plusieurs milliards d'euros ou de
dollars et on est en capacité de ramener
les quelques centaines de grammes dans
certains cas quelques missions Apollo
ont ramené des centaines de kilos mais
voilà des dizaines de kilos centaines de
kilos grand maximum donc voilà ramener
au prix du kilo ça fait quand même très
très cher la ressource extraterrestre
donc voilà par contre comme on le disait
tout à l'heure à des fins logistiques
pour développer enfin permettre la vie
sur des périodes plus longues pour des
missions Artémis futures qui vont aller
se poser sur le sol de la lune là oui ça
peut prendre du sens
Forget pourquoi je reprends les infos
que donnait Mathias pourquoi les
américains adoptent cette loi qui
autorise les entreprises à son parer des
ressources extraites dans l'espace il
pose un jalon oui il y a
c'est vrai que il y a une réflexion à ce
sujet encore une fois
vraiment vous l'avez dit parce qu'elle
vient de le dire il y a quasiment pour
l'instant rien d'intéressant sur la lune
etc ce qui est parfois évoqué c'est
l'exploitation astéroïde peut certaines
stories sont vraiment très riches en
métaux et pour l'instant c'est pas du
tout rentable
sur Mars
planète terre désertique et qui est qui
est très compliqué d'accès donc on est
vraiment très très loin le seul truc
encore une fois qui pourrait être
intéressant ce serait peut-être
l'expression de certaines astéroïdes et
ça reste encore la science-fiction je
risque de répéter ce que dit Pascal là
pour le coup la notion de pour clarifier
dans quelques années il est très
probable que la NASA ouvre un appel
d'offre vraiment un appel d'offres en
disant chers amis entreprises
industrielle qui peut nous fournir
quelques tonnes de glace d'eau sur la
lune et donc là il y a des entreprises
qui vont dire oui moi je peux avec ton
argent et puis voilà il y aura une
espèce d'enchère etc donc revenons très
important sur cette histoire de
ressources puisque des fois on lit tout
et son contraire j'avoué dans les
journaux ou sur internet pour l'instant
il y a rien de magique donc vous donne
un exemple partout vous lirez que c'est
formidable à l'une on va exploiter un
truc qui s'appelle l'hélium 3 c'est une
espèce de de marronnier vous voudriez
vous
ça va être formidable il y a plein
d'argent à se faire rien du tout
l'hélium 3 c'est censé être utilisé
alors c'est une une variante de l'hélium
d'accord donc et c'est historiquement
dans la science-fiction des années 60
quasiment reconnu comme étant un élément
utile pour faire pour pour faire de la
fusion nucléaire pour apporter une
énergie importante dans l'avenir un pour
l'instant n'y arrive pas du tout sur
terre contrairement à ce qu'on pensait à
quelques années deux il y en a vraiment
pas beaucoup sur la lune donc c'est un
espèce de fantasme c'est tout à fait
exemple de de voilà de rumeurs inutile
mais ouais allez même sur sur
l'exploitation des astéroïdes le
Luxembourg qui est quand même un des
pays très en pointe sur ces questions
d'exploration d'exploitation des
ressources extraterrestres ne voit pas
ça avant une vingtaine d'années dans le
meilleur des cas donc on est vraiment
comme sur des choses très mais alors
science-fiction Philippe pourquoi il y a
tant de pays qui je retourne sur sur la
lune à ce moment là on peut faire la
liste parce que là on parle beaucoup des
Américains et de l'Europe mais mais il y
a des Chinois
qui ont un programme lunaire et assumé
avec à l'horizon 2030 la l'ambition
d'avoir des astronautes qui marchent sur
la lune et l'installation d'une base
peut-être un collaboration avec la
Russie bon il y a on voit que les blocs
se refont sur sur un autre corps céleste
et les États-Unis et à l'Europe et
l'Europe est en train de monter à bord
d'Artémis
en Inde aussi
mais il y a eu des robots mais pas
lunaire pour l'instant
l'un des prix après c'est vrai qu'il y a
un certain nombre de puissance
émergentes plus ou moins entre
guillemets puissances spatiales comme
l'Inde il y a bien sûr le Japon Israël
par exemple envoyer une petite mission
qui s'est crashé
sur la lune pourquoi parce que c'est un
peu comme nous en Europe on a de
certaines fiertés notamment à faire des
missions robotiques là on parle beaucoup
d'humains d'hommes dans l'espace mais
l'émission robotique c'est quand même
moins cher très intéressante
scientifiquement elle se justifie
uniquement par la science et bah il y a
différents pays qui souhaitent
s'impliquer là-dedans exactement comme
on a fait nous à notre époque on peut
citer les Emirats Arabes Unis ouais
toutes sortes de pays comme ça donc vous
avez raison pas mal de pays s'y
intéressent avec une idée de prestige de
de susciter par exemple pour ce qui est
des émirats à Unis leur grande
motivation c'est de susciter des
vocations chez les jeunes pour devenir
ingénieur informaticien c'est des choses
qui le rapport ils considèrent que le
rapport d'investissement pour leur
procrastinationales pour citer des
vocations etc c'est ça vaut le coup et
donc beaucoup de pays le font Guillaume
est-ce que ça veut dire qu'il peut y
avoir dans les années à venir une
nouvelle course vers la lune parce que
vous dites d'ici 2030 pour les Chinois
est-ce qu'il va y avoir une guéguerre
entre les Américains avec les
Européennes et les Chinois sur qui
revient le premier sur la lune ou course
parce que les Américains ont toujours
été aiguillonnés comme ça c'était le cas
dans les années 60 le fait même qu'il
existe un programme lunaire chinois les
aiguillonnés sert surtout qu'on n'est
pas très loin dans les dans les dates
parce que ils disent 2030 et si les
Américains réussissent à poser le pied
sur la Lune avant 2028 ce sera déjà un
exploit non c'est c'est ça parce que
pour l'instant la date annoncée
officiellement par Bill Nelson
l'administrateur de la NASA c'est
Artémis 3 on pose deux Américains sur la
Lune en 2025 fin 2025 sauf que le Human
landing system le Starship de de Space X
n'est pas prêt du tout
et ben on ne sait pas puisqu'on ne sait
pas quand est-ce que les Américains
seront prêts c'est à dire que les
Chinois eux on voit bien que quand ils
ont un programme en général ils s'y
tiennent à moins d'un gros pépin
technique mais par exemple regardez leur
station spatiale autour de la Terre
sur de quoi par exemple sur le sur ce
qui concerne le cette compétition il y a
une manière de le voir le Space consille
on a parlé tout à l'heure de
kamalaharissa réglementation si vous
regardez espèce de résumé leur feuille
de travail c'est très impressionnant la
première motivation actuellement de
l'homme de l'exploration de la lune puis
de mars il a été écrit que les
États-Unis doivent continuer à explorer
ses corps car sinon d'autres le feront
et ensuite ils ne les États-Unis ne
pourront points ne pourront plus être à
la table des négociations pour décider
des nouveaux traités c'est écrit comme
ça donc c'est cet esprit là c'est tout à
fait la guerre froide la guerre contre
le communisme mais il y a cette idée il
faut pas que les Chinois soient seuls
dans l'espace alors c'est drôle parce
que vous disiez taikonaute on a révisé
un peu avec l'équipe de sciences
publiques donc un astronaute c'est un
Américain cosmonaute c'est un c'était un
soviétique c'est un Russe spationaute
c'est pour les Européens taikonaute
effectivement pour les Chinois et puis
alors effectivement on a trouvé vieux
manaudes pour les pour les Indiens donc
voilà il y a peut-être nous manquer un
nom pour les Japonais alors jouer il
nous reste à les 5 minutes je vois quand
même qu'on rappelle un peu en détail à
quel point c'est un c'est un défi
technologique un exploit d'aller vivre
sur cette planète Pascal
ultra la le regolith je crois qu'on dit
de le regolithe donc cette poussière de
lune là dont on parle c'est quand même
un poison pour il faut expliquer
pourquoi c'est si compliqué c'est il y a
pas il y a pas d'érosion sur la lune
donc extrêmement coupants abrasif et ça
pose pas mal de problèmes des missions
Apollo on rencontrait cette difficulté
ça effectivement ça se ça se colle sur
les sur les
combinaison et et ça ça risque
d'engendrer des coupures
en fait ce sont des c'est la surface de
la Lune qui est pulvérisée en permanence
par des météorites toutes tailles y
compris des micro météorites qui
arrivent à des vitesses bien supérieures
à celle d'une balle de fusil enfin c'est
à plusieurs kilomètres voire dizaines de
kilomètres à la seconde donc ça fait
cette poudre mais si vous la regardez au
microscope c'est comme des des lames de
rasoir en fait des des choses très
acérées et donc ça colle et ça se met
partout et quand on le respire ça crée
des allergies la dernière mission il y a
50 ans exactement était en route la
mission Apollo 17 avec Harrison Schmitt
et ginsernum qui ont été les dernières
marchés sur la lune à l'issue de leur
trois jours d'exploration et ils étaient
irrités ils avaient les yeux rouges ils
avaient des symptômes de de rhume en
fait mais c'était de respirer cette
poussière qui est un vrai défi technique
pour les prochains qui iront on essaie
d'imaginer des des manières qu'il
faudrait laisser une partie de la
combinaison à l'extérieur du module pour
pas faire rentrer cette poussière
abrasive dans le dans les astronautes
parce que là à l'époque la Polo c'était
du camping on ouvrait là la toile de
tente on sortait et puis on ramenait le
sable avec ça donc
c'est c'est un problème là on essaie
d'imaginer des
solution pour garder la poussière à
l'extérieur parce qu'elle est vraiment
elle est vraiment problématique François
forgé il y a quoi il y a aussi je sais
plus c'est le bon terme mais l'histoire
des il y a les radiations aussi il y a
l'exposition radiation alors c'est vrai
aussi pour la Station spatiale
internationale mais c'est un peu moins
vrai pour la Station spatiale
internationale parce que donc ces
radiations si vous imaginez c'est
essentiellement le soleil une partie qui
vient de mon cosmique qui vient du reste
de la galaxie et c'est des la plupart du
temps ce sont des des rayonnements qui
peuvent à terme créer le cancer de temps
en temps il y a des éruptions solaires
et si vous êtes vraiment en maillot de
bain dans votre petite capsule sans
faire attention vous risquez d'être
vraiment
abîmé de faire de brûler etc donc c'est
un problème alors quand on est sur la
Station spatiale internationale comme
c'est particules dont je vous parle très
énergétiques sont chargées c'est pas
compliqué elles sont déviées par le
champ magnétique de la Terre d'accord
c'est ce qui crée d'ailleurs les aurores
boréales pour faire très simple
simplifier et là la Station spatiale
internationale et et en dessous de ce
bouclier et donc sur la Lune est sur la
lune alors
laisseront le plus en danger en d'autres
termes ceux avec lequel on va le plus
apprendre c'est ceux qui seront sur la
petite station spatiale dont on a parlé
le Lunar Gateway car eux ils seront
vraiment exposés sur la lune la bonne
nouvelle c'est qu'il y a quand même
toute une partie du rayonnement qui ne
vient pas puisque rien ne passe à
travers le sol néanmoins oui c'est un
danger il est on pourra imaginer et
scénario tout à fait plausible quand il
y aura des missions soit sur le Gaito
way soit sur la sur la lune elle-même on
vous vivrez l'action suivante ah une
grande tempête solaire une un flot de
particules en train d'arriver
protégez-vous actuellement ce qui est
prévu par exemple c'est des astronautes
ailes se cacher dans la capsule Orion
qui sera attaché par exemple à la
lunargetaway ou alors sur la sur la lune
ils iront dans un coin et ils se mettra
des paquets c'est prévu des paquets avec
qui contient beaucoup d'eau qui aident à
ralentir les cas les particules et
restaurant là quelques heures et puis
après la tempête s'arrêtera puis
ressortiront alors ça veut dire par nos
interrompre ça veut dire que dans une
station spatiale internationale on il y
a pas un matériau qui peut protéger de
ses radiations cosmiques non c'est un
bon point c'est particulier très
énergétique bah tu les protons c'est
très difficile à arrêter il faudrait une
bonne épaisseur de plomb par exemple et
donc ce serait trop lourd on peut pas
emporter
pas mal c'est l'eau pour vous donner un
petit exemple ça vaut tellement le coup
que on envisage pour l'émission plus
tard vers Mars d'emmener bien sûr de
l'eau mais on se pense même que
contrairement à ce qu'on fait d'habitude
d'emmener de des aliments surgelés parce
qu'ils sont plein d'eau les éléments
surgelés et alors comme ça les armes
surgelés ils serviront de bouclier parce
qu'on a besoin de l'eau pour se protéger
dernière question qui est anée
anecdotique mais non puisque il s'agit
de la nourriture moi j'ai en tête le le
film seul sur Mars où il fait pousser
ses patates là est-ce qu'on pourra faire
pousser quelque chose sur la Lune
est-ce que ça fait partie des
pistes des pistes qui est un genre de
choses ou alors d'emmener aussi des des
alvins de poissons pour pour
effectivement avoir des poissons qui
grandissent sur la Lune en ce qui est
dans des aquariums spéciaux enfin voilà
il imagination est en marche pour ce
genre de choses c'est pour ça que ce
thème de passionne merci de nous avoir
fait rêver c'était vraiment très
intéressant de participer en tant
qu'animateur à ce débat merci beaucoup
et oui oui
j'ai aucune action mais c'est vraiment
passionnant ça donne le sentiment qu'il
y a 50 ans quand même ils étaient
sacrément fort oui bien sûr bien sûr
c'est véritable ils ont tout inventé en
quelques années c'est assez fascinant
introspectivement merci encore d'avoir
participé à ce débat merci à toutes et à
tous de votre fidélité à Sens public
votre prochain rendez-vous demain matin
Oriane Mancini reçoit Mathias wargon le
médecin
urgentiste belle soirée à toutes et à
tous sur Public Sénat et sur les chaînes
parlementaires
[Musique]